thank you very much for your time thank
you
history professor jeremy kuzmarov says
that rumors of widespread drug use by
soldiers during the vietnam war are
wrong
he says that both supporters and members
of the anti-war movement promoted the
idea
the university of arkansas at
fayetteville is the host of this event
it's about an hour and a half
it's my pleasure to be here uh a
live report issued by the un office on
drugs and crime estimated total revenues
for the global drug trade to be 320
billion uh dollars per year uh greater
than the gdp of 80 percent is worldwide
similarly the us federal and state
prison population reached a new
1.5 million in 2007
increase of 15 percent since 2001
around one half of federal and
one-fourth of state inmates locked up
for drug offenses
clearly the war on drugs as rob pointed
out and well first initiated by
president richard m nixon more than 35
years ago has been a failure certainly
in stemming the global or domestic drug
trade and yet drug policies have changed
little if at all since nixon's
pronouncement
as i argue in my book the myth of the
addicted army vietnam and the modern war
on drugs the growth of the modern u.s
drug war by nixon was the product of
domestic hysteria that developed as a
result of exaggerated stories about the
use of drugs by american soldiers in
vietnam
amidst widening dissent against the war
including from u.s troops which is a
well-known story as it should be
nixon exploited public concerns about
drugs to his advantage
found the perfect political remedy to
deflect public attention away from the
horrors of the war in vietnam and
popular attention
sorry popular opposition to the war this
is the basic thesis of the book
the issue of drugs in vietnam first
grabbed the public's attention in
january
with the publication of a controversial
article in the washingtonian magazine by
the son of the famous novelist john
steinbeck
titled the importance of being stoned in
vietnam
and steinbeck claimed this article that
75 percent of soldiers smoke marijuana
in vietnam and that quote the average
soldier sees that for all intents and
purposes the entire country is stoned to
enforce prohibition against smoking the
plant in vietnam would be like trying to
prohibit the inhalation of smog in los
angeles
words were evocative and drugs were
certainly prevalent in vietnam there was
an element of exaggeration
military psychiatrists working closest
to the situation found that between 30
and 35 used marijuana during their tour
largely on an experimental basis to
escape the harsh realities of war and in
some cases
defiance
toward the end of the war roughly 5 to
10 percent experimented with a form of
smokeable heroin known as skag which was
made available by the opening of
transportation routes following the us
invasion of cambodia in 1970
a dissolution veteran who had been
arrested on marijuana possession charges
as steinbeck over dramatized the scope
of drug use in vietnam because as he
told his famous father who
his outlook
that quote if they were smoking it as
respected and lauded soldiers over there
how could it be they were criminals
what i wanted to do was to paint this
ridiculous contradiction
uh rife with exaggeration star
steinbeck's article nevertheless had an
effect far beyond its original
expectation it gave rise
term the myth of the addicted army
allege that drug use was widespread or
omnipresent in vietnam contributed to
the breakdown in the military's fighting
capabilities
adopting hyperbolic
epidemics and plagues proponents of this
myth equated all drug use with abuse and
downplayed the differences among drugs
marijuana for example as being equally
powerful and addictive as heroin they
neglected the social context in which
gis got stoned between the link to
anti-war protests within the military
which was quite market and also the
confinement of drug use mainly to the
rear not to the front lines they firm
are proponents of the myth for their
blame drugs for a host of military
problems including lack of discipline
sabotage combat refusals and civilian
that could be more reasonably attributed
to the prolongation of war that had lost
any sense of purpose certainly by
1969-1970
by the time the myth of the addicted
army reached its zenith in 1971 with
proliferation of reports of the spread
of heroin and it already had a
pronounced public impact it helped
divert public attention away from the
quality policies that
perpetuated the vietnam war
while at the same time intensifying
public fears of the growth of the 1960s
drug culture and thus create an
opportune political climate for an
expansion of the federal drug war which
the nixon administration would
capitalize on
in preventing the kind of sustainable
searching and rethink of values that
might have emerged from an honest
accounting of the us involvement in
vietnam the myth of the addicted army
served a similar ideological function to
three additional cultural myths
related to the american experience in
vietnam
one of these myths is the prisoner of
war myth
which the nixon administration in this
initially used to justify a prolongation
of the war and later provided rationale
for condemning the peace settlement that
ended it
equally prominent in american popular of
course on the prisoner of war meth
there's never been any evidence that's
come about that
the north vietnamese government kept u.s
soldiers
after
reached this was part of the myth that
was used to continue the us involvement
and later took root deeply within u.s
popular culture another myth is the
so-called stab in the back myth which
bears resemblance the german dolce
legend after world war one
it blames weak-willed politicians
treasonous anti-war protesters and
dissenting journalists
provide the necessary moral support to
the troops in vietnam and constraining
american military power hence breeding
defeat
intricately connected
was the spat upon veteran myth which
indicts the anti-war movement for
allegedly maltreating usgis upon their
return home even though hard evidence of
such maltreatment is hard to come by
all of these myths have been promoted
most vigorously by conservatives and
neo-conservatives eager to justify the
revival of an aggressive foreign policy
after vietnam
great the vietnam era anti-war movement
each took root because of unwillingness
on the part of many americans to bear
responsibility for their actions or the
country's actions in vietnam
because the culture at large could not
accept defeat at the hands of a quote
inferior people or quote raggedy ass
fourth rate power as lyndon johnson had
characterized the vietnamese it searched
for alternative explanation became
institutionalized over time
together these myths helped to preserve
the nation's vision of righteousness and
the dominant liberal internationalist
creed which asserted that america had
both a duty and right to export liberal
capitalist ideals in a developing world
by force if necessary
the myths helped to refocus public
hostility moreover on a series of
scapegoats including ineffectual
bureaucrats anti-war activists and
liberal journalists along with the
pernicious evil of drug abuse which
emerged as a symbol of the war's tragedy
whose eradication was deemed necessary
to restore america's international
credibility and prestige
the myth of the addicted army was
promoted most vigorously by the mass
media because explosive drug stories
helped to sell papers and drawn viewers
for television
many journalists referred directly to
steinbeck's inflated estimates which
they accepted uncritically and pointed
to the ravaging effects of drug use in
combat even though such use was
predominantly rare was mostly used in
the rear they adopted a narco phobic
discourse encompassing lures and
orientalist stereotypes depicting
depicting drugs as a foreign corrupting
agent reminiscent of the worst anti-drug
propaganda campaigns of the past
typical was a january 1971 newsweek
article entitled the troubled us army in
vietnam which proclaimed the drug
situation to be a nightmare even some of
the medics are on heroin using needles
from our own stores the authors wrote
amidst lurid photos of
high you could see the punctures right
up and down there
in fact a heroin use by needle was very
very rare in vietnam it was usually
smoked when taken at all the new york
times depicted gis preoccupied with
planning pot parties and two strung out
to mount any effective military
campaigns jack anderson of the
washington post was wrote some of the
most inflammatory pieces based on rumor
and hearsay claiming that soldiers on
drugs were firing at their own troops
giving away military positions and even
selling military secrets such as the
timing of bombing raids to prostitutes
actually there's no evidence to indicate
that these charges are true again drugs
was used but not to the extent
pointed out in these articles in fact
internal military reports studied the
issue and depicted drug abuse as more of
a minor problem yielding no discernible
impact on morale health welfare
efficiency or combat effectiveness the
major problem the military as
public relations how the stories of drug
use much like stories of atrocities that
were coming out were giving a bad
reputation to the military they were
less concerned about the effect of drugs
on combat performance which got
exaggerated
as during the korean war
journalists portrayed the spread of drug
abuse as a weapon of sabotage by
communist agents in november 1967 nbc
anchorman walter cronkite proclaimed
quote the communists are battling
american troops not only with firepower
but with drugs
internal military reports however we can
see the distortion that sometimes at
play in the media the uh the military
reports that i've studied at various
archives
including the national archives uh
showed that through a consultation with
local intelligence that the national
liberation front which was the southern
based resistance movement within vietnam
rarely this i'm quoting from military
documents rarely handled any drugs and
that quote the north vietnamese and
chinese did not figure prominently in
international narcotics trafficking due
to strong anti-narcotics legislation and
quote produced only as much opium as was
needed for internal medical needs
uh the the internal reports also
conceded to the deep corruption of
american allies uh including in laos
thailand as well as south vietnam where
the u.s was supporting very very
names
cronkite's comments revealed a stark
cold war mindset
among journalists who helped to
construct the popular image of a
monolithic communist enemy willing to
resort to any form of treachery and evil
including drug trafficking to ensure
global supremacy
cast aside were the factors shaping the
strength of the revolutionary movements
within vietnam including their appeal to
nationalist sentiment uh and their
dedication to land reform and literacy
campaigns which had helped them to win
over most of the countryside as again
internal military reports conceded
the media at the same time through this
fixation with drugs and u.s soldiers
helped to displace the reality of burned
villages napalm children and teeming
urban slums bred by the u.s bombing
and pacification campaigns which were
these elements of the war were quietly
swept from public attention amidst this
frenzy about drugs
in may 71 newsweek columnist stuart
alsop went so far as to claim that quote
the drug drug epidemic was worse than
the milai massacre where u.s soldiers
had killed an estimated 504 vietnamese
civilians and quote the worst horror to
have emerged from the war in addition to
the 55 000 americans who have died in
vietnam there are now many more
thousands addicted to heroin who might
as well be dead
uh these comments are quite astonishing
at least to me uh especially considering
the physical devastation to say that
the drug use was the worst [ __ ]
considering the physical devastation
wrought by u.s policies in indochina
including the creation of at least seven
million refugees vietnamese refugees
destruction of large swaths of the
countryside through one of the most
sustained bombing attacks in history as
well as chemical defoliation and killing
anywhere from two to five million uh
indochinese people
these kind of comments by people like
also reveal in my view at least a narrow
cultural mindset all too typical of the
american establishment which placed the
primacy on the cost of the war to the
united states while callously ignoring
its far more calamitous effects on the
population of vietnam
al-sabdo was not alone in using morbid
analogies surrounding drugs reminiscent
of the anslinger heyday and uh most
you're probably familiar with the
legendary harry j anslinger the head of
the federal bureau of narcotics from
1929 through the early 60s who was
influential in drumming up federal
support for the war on drugs
through his notorious reefer madner
madness campaigns
and all kinds of embellishments
about the effects of marijuana but these
reports
i'm trying to argue that the reports in
vietnam that resembled anslinger
rhetoric and exaggeration
the reader's digest for example likened
an opium den frequented by usgis to
quote a nazi death camp where men a
little more than skeletons stats sat
staring blankly into space rising every
30 minutes to buy more drugs the far
eastern economic review editorialized
that addicted veterans whereas badly
named from the wars they're visibly
crippled comrades while the new york
times correspondent james reston wrote
that the drug crisis was quote one of
those tragic consequences of the war
where nikita khrushchev's phrase the
living may envy the dead
these comments epitomize the tone of
outrage characterizing the media's
response to the drug crisis in stark
contrast the violence bred by the war
itself where there was very little moral
exhortations
at the same time to show the breadth of
their exaggerations about drugs which in
turn promoted the popular conception of
vietnam as a war that had been tainted
and marred by drugs with devastating
social effect
while cementing anti-drug moraes in the
united states
many articles warn in sensationalistic
fashion that the so-called drug drug
epidemic in vietnam was spreading back
to the united states
in february of 71 also
and also was a very influential
commentator of that period his brother
joseph was actually on the payroll of
the cia
but a very influential journalist he
wrote a column called the smell of death
in which he warned that new york city
was becoming quote infested with drugs
and killed by heroin largely due the
return of addicted soldiers other
american cities are on the death list
but new york may be terminal again shows
this kind of demonization
and rhetoric which i argue is what
fueled support for the war on drugs
incidentally none of alsop's writing
mentioned the far more deplorable
conditions in saigon bred by the u.s
bombings and refugee crisis
nor did he explore the underlying
structural variables and abandonment of
great society programs shaping the
breakdown of america's inner cities in
this period which he ascribed to drugs
and crazy veterans returning to the
streets but were in fact the product of
structural problems economic problems
and the cut back in government programs
in june of 71 time linked the return of
strung out vets to a quote frightening
rise in the nation's crime rate the
authors editorialized the specter of
weapons-trained addicted combat veterans
joining the deadly street struggle for
drugs in the streets of america is
ominous within a matter of months in our
large cities the capone era of the 1920s
may look like a sunday school picnic
so again i think we see the exaggeration
contrary to this image in 73 there was a
study by a psychiatrist at washington
university leanne robbins
she interviewed many veterans who had
tested positive for heroin in vietnam
and concluded that less than 10 percent
used any drugs at all back in the united
states
many did use
alcohol and some did use barbiturates
but heroin use was especially low
and those
the number of less than 10 was an
extraordinarily high remission rate
which robin's attributed to their
removal from the pernicious social
environment of vietnam
only 1.3 percent of those sampled were
drug dependent and less than one percent
addicted to opiates
drug abuse and crime rates were
generally exaggerated in the media
creating a climate of fear that allowed
for the escalation of the war on drugs
in 1980 the washington post tellingly
editorialized a decade a po a decade ago
reports of widespread heroin use by u.s
troops in vietnam spawned fears that
servicemen would come home with their
drug habits leading to a generation of
drug enslavement crime and ruined lives
today it's clear that those fears were
grossly exaggerated
generally you know vietnam veterans got
tarred by these stereotypes many uh in
fact achieved you know very high levels
of education
and income levels many also emerged
politically awakened from their
experience and protested the war as
leaders of the peace movement which got
obscured in all of these uh
sensationalistic portrayals and focus on
their drug use uh the media you know
created the impression of the amer
instead of uh you know profiling the the
role of soldiers in the peace movement
and the substantial criticism of u.s
policy that they had derived from their
experience in vietnam they created the
impression that america's social fabric
was being torn apart at the seams by
half crazed and doped up soldiers from
whom nobody was safe the result was to
raise support for nixon's law and order
program while also tarnishing the image
of vietnam veterans uh and you know
their
courage and sacrifice and resisting and
unjust war was quietly swept from public
consciousness much like the fate of
indo-chinese crushed by the weight of
american napalm and artillery
many of the sensationalistic media
portrayals drew from a series of
congressional subcommittee hearings led
by senator thomas j dodd from
connecticut democrat
and these were designed in the words of
dr roger rothman
who was a psychiatric social worker who
testified at the committee
to quote maximize public alarm by
broadcasting the most extreme dimensions
of the crisis
god claimed that drug abuse was quote an
evil tied to setting the nation
responsible for quote excessive troop
casualties and shocking crimes such as
shoulders soldiers shooting kernels
going partially insane and degenerating
to a state where they were totally
ineffective he also blamed marijuana for
the milai massacre claiming that two
soldiers since they had smoked marijuana
the night before
that they had gone crazy
and as a result shot up a vietnamese
village so we see the connection with
the anslingers because anslinger had
claimed that marijuana caused insanity
and he pointed to a case of a kid in
florida who killed his family and
claimed that it was because he had
smoked marijuana so there's a parallel
with dodd trying to claim that marijuana
was responsible for the milan massacre
[Music]
while there were isolated instances of
dereliction of duty caused by drugs a
psychiatrist working closely with
soldiers found firstly that alcohol was
linked more acutely to cases of
psychiatric breakdown than drugs
actually i've got a section in the book
called the alcoholic army in vietnam
because alcohol was epidemic as
concluded by the military high command
and many of the officers were alcoholics
the psychiatrist also concluded that
drugs helped soldiers actually to cope
with stresses and horrors of that
conflict
in a personal memoir the drug haze war
in southeast asia sergeant j.d rieble
who served with the 4th battalion 60th
artillery from october 67 to june 69
commented for many of us drugs were a
form of self-medication i daydreamed
under their influence they offered a
temporary release from the constant fear
and physical suffering
mark levy a medic with the first cavalry
division recounted the story of a
wounded gi who demanded a toke from a
joint before being medevaced to a nearby
hospital he was lying on a stretcher
with shrapnel wounds on his leg and just
blurted out give me a joint now that's
marijuana medical marijuana in action
levy said you have to realize that when
we were out in the jungle the tension
would build up like a coil over several
days combat was the equivalent of sex
and that it released all the emotional
drain and produced an incredible rush of
energy he needed something to come down
after that and drugs like marijuana
provided the perfect tranquilizing
effect
dr peter born chief of neuropsychiatry
section of the u.s army medical research
team and a founder of vietnam veterans
against the war
he commented quote use of drugs in the
combat zone has a particular appeal
because the psychological anesthesia
provides a ready antidote to
environmental stress
soldiers know how near they have come to
dying and about the possibility of death
in the future and they feel no
compunction about immersing themselves
in immediate gratification
in terms of the link of atrocities these
were best attributed to what the
psychiatrist robert j lifton referred to
as quote the atrocity producing
environment of the war in vietnam fought
by an advanced technological power
against a popularly backed revolutionary
movement and his acclaimed book vietnam
veterans neither victims nor
executioners lift and stress the
importance of drug use also as a symbol
of defiance in the military an aspect of
the war generally forgotten today but
quite well documented in internal
military reports
both the media and senator dodd chose to
ignore the underlying roots of drug use
in the military while exaggerating its
scope and effects and facilitating the
breakdown of the armed forces of which
it was a symptom and not a cause the
consequences were profound creating a
distorted impression about drug abuse in
vietnam while turning attention away
from the suffering of the vietnamese
population
ironically given the long-term
ramifications the anti-war movement and
political left were themselves quite
vocal in broadcasting the ravaging
effects of drug abuse in vietnam in
large part because they blame the
government for addicting its own troops
now this was actually true as i have a
lot of evidence to broadcast
during the mid 60s the rumors first
emerged that the central intelligence
agency was providing logistical support
for drug traffickers in southeast asia
who were allies or proxies in the fight
against communism
now political activists and leading
democratic doves like george mcgovern
seized upon this information which did
prove to be largely true and there's a
lot of new archival evidence
to confirm a deep complicity of the cia
and u.s government agencies
but nevertheless left because of this
they at times employed some of the same
exaggerations
as the mainstream in 1971 for instance
left-wing ramparts which to its great
credit did help to expose uh the role of
the cia
but to give you a sense of some of the
overblown rhetoric in one of their
editorials they noted the u.s went on a
holy war to stamp out communism and to
protect its asian markets and its
conscripted sons have come home with a
blood stained needle as their only
lasting souvenir it's a fitting
trade-off one that characterizes the
moral quality of the us involvement
which has radiated a nimbus of genocide
and corruption
this ugly war keeps coming back to haunt
us each manifestation more terrifying
than the last
seeing the international drug trade as a
form of economic imperialism the
anti-war left helped to cement the
public impression that drugs were
lasting legacy
of america's disastrous intervention in
vietnam and menace to the social order
they further contributed to a
transformation of the image of vietnam
veterans from agents of imperialism as
many came to see themselves
to pathological victims of an unpopular
war upon whom public fears became
transfixed
robert lifton observed that quote as the
particular taint of vietnam found
appropriate of tragic public symbolism
in the heroin epidemic
the men who encounter evil and war take
on its particular taint or sickness in
the form of heroin the society that sent
them becomes terrified of them the fear
of contagion remains acute as do images
of infected men returning to spread
their plague the government's term
throughout the mother country now the
addicts instead of the war itself and
the way we are fighting it becomes the
locus of evil
the problem when finally acknowledged
becomes drug addiction and that we are
told is what must be overcome
drug addiction not
you know the war or what had led u.s
into vietnam
richard nixon
enter nixon he was particularly shrewd i
argue in exploiting the drug crisis in
vietnam to his political advantage
he exaggerated the menace of drug abuse
in an slingerous way in his rhetoric and
he effectively presented himself as a
national savior bent on eradicating the
drug peril from american life
on june 17th 1971 after the release of a
congressional report claiming
exaggeratingly as it turned out that 15
percent of american gis had used heroin
nixon formally declared his war on drugs
calling drug abuse quote public enemy
number one in america
the situation he says approach the
dimensions of a national emergency
now the timing of the speech was very
opportune for nixon
four days earlier the new york times had
begun printing excerpts of the pentagon
papers
uh which and apparently there's a very i
haven't seen it yet but there's an
excellent new documentary out on daniel
ellsberg in his role in linking
leaking the pentagon papers
the pentagon papers was a top secret
blueprint of american governmental war
planning
leaked by ellsberg
and it showed a pattern of
deception by the government
and also the imperial motives that drove
the us into vietnam so this was
certainly bad public relations for the
u.s government popular support for the
war especially as nixon had come into
office claiming peace with honor but was
perpetuating the war
now popular support by this point had
reached a low ebb falling below 25
percent uh with some of the most
protracted opposition coming from within
the ranks of servicemen
in april 1971 anti-war veterans
described by the washington evening post
as quote hippies with combat infantry
badges and purple hearts
gathered for a special ceremony where
they denounced u.s aggression and war
crimes in vietnam and hurled their
medals at the pentagon vowing that the
only way they would fight again would be
to quote take these steps
vietnam veterans against the war
spokesman john f kerry
subsequently excoriated the nixon
administration before the senate foreign
relations committee and the senator jay
william fulbright uh kerry said that
nixon had betrayed the troops and urged
for immediate withdrawal so that no one
else had to die for the biggest nothing
in history and a mistake
on june 18th amidst all these
developments nixon actually received a
flurry of positive letters from
constituents praising his commitment
towards solving the drug crisis which
many consider to be among the greatest
social problems of their time nixon thus
had found the perfect political remedy
to deflect public attention away from
the horrors of vietnam and the popular
opposition to it while pursuing this
elusive and ultimately illusory goal of
peace with honor
now a centerpiece of nixon's drug policy
and basically i argue yet that the nixon
period was you know major watershed saw
major growth in the war on drugs
as we know it today a centerpiece of his
policy was in the military he
established your analysis tests in
vietnam for all departing gi's which was
dub operation golden flow
and also a treatment program and a nice
name a treatment program for soldiers
who tested positive and actually it's
somewhat ironic in spite of his lock him
up and throw away the key rhetoric you
know this tough guy rhetoric and nixon
was actually a major benefactor of drug
treatment increasing the overall budget
from 28 to 300 million
and this budget would be cut in later
years uh under the reagan administration
as the uh
drug war bureaucracy focused
increasingly on enforcement but nixon
was actually a proponent of treatment at
the same time though he did expand
international interdiction programs on
an unprecedented scale with a focus in
southeast asia
unrecognized to many historians nixon's
escalation of the war on drugs was
central to his vietnamization policy
its primary aim besides bolstering the
reputation of the armed forces and
easing public anxieties about the return
of addicted vets was to improve the
image of american governmental allies in
the south vietnamese government so as to
allow for its political sustainability
this government was marred by scandal
with the revelations that was deeply
corrupted in the drug traffic it was
also implicated in major human rights
violations including the notorious tiger
cages of conson
so by trying to pressure them to crack
down on drugs he's trying to get you
know improve their public image to allow
for the sustainability of u.s strategy
that through vietnamization was
basically trying to prop up that
government
as u.s gradually began to scale down
troops
um
so yeah i mean he pressured it was the
few government of south vietnam to crack
down on the traffic purge corrupt
officials and also spent millions
training local police initiating crop
substitution and aerial spraying
campaigns
nevertheless for all the millions in a
prelude to later failures supply rates
remain static and corruption rampant a
june 1972 army criminal investigation
report concluded that quote enforcement
remain futile as distribution through
local nationals in south vietnam was so
pervasive that efforts to cut off the
supply were like trying to quote
imprison the morning mist
local farmers often resisted u.s
policies by shooting at overhead planes
to prevent them from spraying their
fields
a few were brought to testify before
congressional committee the kennedy
hearing on refugees about how chemical
springs got into their livestock and led
to major health problems and in some
cases death
the pattern is now being repeated today
in latin america as many who are
probably aware as well as afghanistan
where the u.s is destroying poor farmers
livelihood and poisoning their crops
while at the same time they're
supporting leading drug lords and
financing some of its state terror
operations against the taliban and
pashtuni resistance forces through the
drug traffic just as the u.s financed
the secret war in laos through opium
grown by indigenous hmong tribesmen whom
it recruited into a clandestine secret
army
and
specific references to ahmed wali karzai
is the brother of hameed karzai who the
new york times
did a big expose showing how he's the
major drug traffickers in afghanistan
today
now in terms of the u.s drug war in asia
and my argument is that that set a
precedent
for subsequent policies
i mean part of the failure of that
policy was because the u.s continued to
support regimes of as the historian
alfred w mccoy termed them regimes of
total corruption
the other problem was
predicated on a similar factor shaping
the overriding failure of u.s foreign
policy namely the inability to win the
hearts and minds of the population
the state department and federal
enforcement agencies face grave
difficulties adapting to local
circumstances and convincing the native
population to stop profiting from the
drug trade in a depressed wartime
economy
chao la a yao chief of the opiate
growing nam kwang province bordering
thailand and also a cia asset told an
american reporter that quote what the
protestant ethic of american society
sees as corrupt others see as fair game
it is hard for my people to understand
why they should stop growing opium
because they are told it affects
americans thousands of miles away in a
strange country
american ambassador to laos gene
mcmurtry godly who presided over one of
the most intense bombing campaigns in
world history
similarly observed in laos that quote
there was no underworld stigma attached
to any of the local principles or fetch
and carry men who transported drugs
through luang prabang in laos
in a memo to washington explaining the
difficulty of u.s drug control efforts
he recounted an incident which he turned
pathetic where laotian municipal
officers gave opium to several men that
they had arrested on drug charges out of
fear that they would develop painful
withdrawal symptoms the police chief
subsequently told him we had to find
opium for them to smoke otherwise
because of a strong craving for the drug
they would scream cry or raise a hue
so this is not a very good prospect for
success if the police are giving opium
to people they're arresting
for
drug violations and i think the comments
epitomize the deep barriers and we see a
continuity across time deep barriers
plaguing american drug control efforts
and it's apparent a naturalist to the
setting be it southeast asia or be it
central asia today
the comments served i think as a
microcosm for the broader peril of
trying to export western ideals in an
often coercive fashion
in spite of many contradictions nixon
was able to score badly needed political
points by his drug policy and appear to
be proactive in confronting a major
societal problem one that was socially
constructed in the press
and nixon's policies would thus become
institutionalized so i mean practically
they were a failure uh human from a
humanitarian level they were a failure
but politically they were good for nixon
because he appeared proactive in
addressing this problem and that's one
reason i think they became
institutionalized during the late 70s
and 80s and expanded on greatly by
ronald reagan who spent over 23 billion
on the drug war thus helping the us to
surpass russia and south africa as the
leading prisoner states in the world
today hundreds of thousands are
imprisoned and what the general barry
mccaffrey the drugs are of the nineties
of all people this is his term not mine
term america's drug gulag
this being the result of draconian
sentencing practices and over policing
in poor inner city communities resulting
in discrimination of blacks and
undermine other minorities under this
policy which is very well documented in
much sociological literature
meanwhile the u.s continues to spend
billions internationally on spring and
defoliation campaigns which have soiled
the land and contributed to many human
rights violations by empowering the
military and police and repressive
regimes worldwide in november 2004 a
civic advocacy group the washington
office on latin america published a
damning report which concluded quote in
one nation after another u.s drug
control policies are undermining human
rights and democracy
by bringing back into domestic law
enforcement the region's militaries
which have not been held accountable for
widespread abuses and authoritarian
dictatorships and are causing enormous
damage to some of the most vulnerable
people in the hemisphere including
impoverished farmers ratcheted down into
deeper poverty with the destruction of
their most important crops the report
continued after 25 years and more than
25 billion dollars we're no closer to
winning the war which is ultimately
about reducing drug abuse there has been
no significant reduction of illicit drug
flows out of the andes or other
countries
now after 89 the war on drugs provide an
important rationale as to why the u.s
continued this policy
in part there may be other reasons but
cold war pretext could not no longer be
applied so it was a good excuse for
continuing u.s intervention
the u.s charged at narco guerrillas
which was a term invented by the
ambassador to colombia in the 80s louis
thames were behind the influx of drugs
in american cities
in fact the drug cartels were on the
right wing of the political spectrum and
opposed any kind of land reform or
wealth redistribution and foreign
paramilitary militias to fight the
guerrillas and were times allied with
u.s backed regimes the guerrillas
generally uh
you know in the case of farc in colombia
for example they taxed cocaine in their
domain they were not necessarily
principal drug traffickers at least in
the 80s from the evidence i see i've
seen the cartels
were on the right wing of the spectrum
and their paramilitaries often worked
with the militaries to fight the
guerrillas who threatened whose policies
particularly the emphasis on land reform
was seen as a threat to these cartels
who
own you know major lands and mansion
indirectly the u.s often
indirectly subsidized the drug traffic
in this way because of the alliance
between the paramilitaries and
militaries as the u.s was funding the
military regimes like colombia
so the us is indirectly subsidizing the
drug traffic they are purportedly
fighting while continuing their agenda
of destroying left-wing guerrilla groups
now as i argue in my book the legacy of
vietnam remain influential in shaping
u.s drug war policies through the 80s
and beyond which was partly due to the
influence of hollywood films like
apocalypse now platoon
and b grade counterparts like the stone
killer and welcome home soldier boy
these films preserved the myth of the
addicted army and distorted public
memory of the war by recasting american
gis in the role of drug-addled victims
and psychopaths
tellingly in 1979 a viewer noted that
quote the networks had discovered a
marketable a marketable villain no
b-grade melodrama was complete without
its standard vet as a psychotic heroin
addict another veteran commented quote
if i acted according to what i have seen
on television in the last six months or
so i should probably be harboring
extreme psychopathic tendencies that
prompt me to shoot up heroin with one
hand while fashioning explosives with
the other
as my drug crazed mind flashes back the
rice paddy where i killed my lieutenant
so
by the 80s americans
through these images had become
saturated with the notion of a country
whose survival was threatened by the
curse of addiction
and the impact should not be
underestimated
taking hold among a wide public audience
these impressions helped elevate drugs
to an issue of central public importance
and bred support for heightened drug
control measures
they also at the same time contributed
to an erasure from public memory of the
intricacies of the vietnam war itself
making it seem as the veteran acclaimed
poet w d earhart noted that quote
vietnam was something that happened to
us as an america when in reality it was
something that we had done to them as in
the vietnamese
instead of questioning the fundamental
tenets of u s foreign policy and empire
a majority of americans consequently
came to embrace domestic policy for
reform as a means of revitalizing the
nation with the war on drugs designed as
a pivotal measure to help fulfill this
end
the devastating scope of america's
aerial bombardment campaign and
suffering of the southeast asian people
including the laos and cambodian people
who are subjected to vicious aerial
attacks was forgotten as the u.s leaders
embarked on a new wave of interventions
in central america placed an embargo in
vietnam rearmed the country for future
wars and fought the war on drugs
endlessly so
thank you
and i'll be happy to address your
questions
but this gives a basic overview of the
themes of the book so
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
so
yeah
during during the 70s you know we had
the uh what people called the flower
children hippies and you know they began
to be called the youth in revolt and
also and use marijuana for instance and
then also in vietnam they did the same
thing on so on these two different
fronts uh so maybe what connections did
the nixon administration make between
the two fronts
good yeah i think that's an excellent
question so the question is to link uh
the link between the counter culture
right uh and the link that nixon tried
to make between the counter culture and
the drug crisis in vietnam
and yeah that's actually central to my
argument is that was a way for nixon and
the conservative movement to attack the
counterculture because they blamed and
this was seemingly the example the fact
that drugs had seeped into the armed
forces the most venerable of all
institutions and most you know
conservative institutions was ridden
with drugs was proof for nixon and his
associates how the counterculture was
destroying america and turning america
in his words to a you know fourth rate
power was what he feared and kissinger
those may have been kissinger's words so
and i think they played it up
deliberately because their agenda the i
mean the entire conservative movement
a strong basis of its agenda is to erase
the 60s
and you know attack the 60s movements
and revive america to what it was in the
50s uh and to revive you know because i
mean one thing the 60s movement did was
to create you know
a mindset of questioning authority and
challenging uh us or at least
questioning us interventions abroad
so that was part of it so yeah i think
very much nixon and his associates
wanted to go after the counterculture
and so they played up the addiction
crisis in the military to show the
pernicious effects of the counterculture
and they use that kind of rhetoric and
that fueled this agenda of which the war
on drugs was a central dimension of
turning the country
you know back to traditional values and
implementing the war on drugs as a means
of counteracting everything that the
youth movements in the 60s represented
so excellent question then
yeah there's two hands i guess we'll go
with you first and then
go
[Music]
so the question is uh if people today
might be more attuned to the prevalence
of propaganda and recognizing uh the
exaggerations uh yeah i think so i think
you have a divided country
at the same time actually i think you
have waning and that's why i think
there's somewhat of a crisis in the
united states because uh there's a
divide between the population and the
government
and government policies in many areas i
think are quite unpopular and i think
the 60s movements one could um
debate what the legacies of the 60s
movements were but i think one legacy
that really took root in society was
to fundamentally transform a the you
know the culture of the country and also
just uh you know to transform cultural
mores and the the spirit of questioning
authority and being critical minded i
think is enduring uh among many youth
and so
i think that it has changed you know
many do recognize the exaggeration but
it still goes on so
why is that
i mean one reason
i mean enough people perhaps do believe
it to you know give enough political
support the kind of leaders who keep
using that kind of rhetoric to get
elected
but at the same time i think it also
does show a growing divide which is why
there's
it has led to perhaps cynicism from what
i've seen among some youth but i think
there is a divide between the population
and the government the the policies and
often values of the government don't
represent uh the values of a good
portion of the population and i think
the drug issue would be
one
prominent example because i think you
know a lot of people are smart and they
can see
uh you know they know either from
personal experience uh life experience
or i mean there's vast literatures uh
out there uh deconstructing a lot of the
mythologies my book is just one of many
with you know particular focus but
there's many other books
showing the hollowness
of many claims so yeah i think there is
a large critical body and mass in
society but there's a divorce between
the policy and the and public rhetoric
of many elected officials
which is a big problem i think in
american life
but
[Music]
so
there was there was another question
um president nixon is regarded as a
more of a big government statist i guess
conservative or
uh politician in that fact modern
conservatism today is rooted around a
smaller government or more libertarian
approach
and i just want to make that distinction
for the public
what would you say would be the
chance that
a more libertarian approach should be
taken
by conservatives
to
a medical solution to america's drug
problems rather than a moralistic
solution
thanks the question is
yeah a emphasizing that nixon was more
um
you know in favor of a big government
compared to subsequent conservative
regimes and then uh posing the question
what uh do i think of the prospects of
the
conservative movement adopting more of a
libertarian approach
on the first question yeah i certainly
agree and actually there's a growing
body of literature on
nixon as a liberal
in the sense that he did implement
certain policies that one might think of
as liberal including drug treatment
would be you know the emphasis on drug
treatment but his drug war yeah it does
show uh the you know big spending
tendencies although i think we see that
as much as the yeah the current
conservatives uh as well as much as they
may claim to be for small government as
we see in a policy like the drug war
they're continuing this tradition
although the difference with and the big
split was with reagan who moved away
from treatment he kept i mean he
escalated the budget to an outrageous
level
because nixon was still in the millions
but reagan and i had to check that
figure because i had that down i was
like this can't be right he spent 23
billion on the drug war and so i you
know i i double checked the fact that i
originally written and i was copy
editing the book and it was right 23
billion by reagan
and most of that money went in for
enforcement uh you know nixon was more
of a mixed bag so a big shift took place
under reagan and i think you know the
bush administration bush one ambush two
continued that pattern of a very high
spending uh
but emphasis on enforcement uh in terms
of drug policy so
that you know so the current state of
the you know conservative movement or
republican party is towards that
tendency as much as they claim to
represent small government so
i'm not sure what the prospects are i
mean it's hard to predict uh i think
there is a a large body of support
of opposition to the drug war
if that will play out in policy is um
i don't know i mean the modern breed of
conservative philosophically argues that
the government role should be limited
except when it comes to defense and
law enforcement
and that seems to be within the
mainstream at least the republican party
today although i know there are splits
with libertarianism so i mean i can't
predict the future
i think public sentiment is more in
favor of a libertarian approach but
whether that will play out in policy i
don't know
i'm not sure
but it's a good question
okay um before vietnam how was drug you
seen and dealt with in the military
um that's a good question well it was uh
policing began uh the problem first
developed in panama in the
early 1900s when u.s soldiers were
policing the
construction of the panama canal
the army always had program world war ii
i've done some research on this
[Music]
i mean there were policing in place
actually what shifted with vietnam was
that uh the army at a certain point
because i mean the army had a basically
zero tolerance approach if you were
found with it you're you know gone i
mean it was really frowned upon
and you know users were harshly dealt
with what happened in vietnam is that so
many were people were using it more on a
casual basis
that for policing
they you know it created all kinds of
logistical problems
and they didn't want to just dismiss
hundreds of soldiers so that's when they
shifted towards putting in treatment
policies uh and nyx in advance kind of
systematized that approach when he put
in this golden flow system so uh in that
period but then again reagan shifted
back
as in late 70s i mean that was a down
period for the u.s military the
reputation of the military after vietnam
was very very low
and reagan tried to revive uh because
you know once vietnam ended those
programs kind of wane but reagan revived
pretty harsh laws
in the military but much like in society
took away the emphasis on treatment
so
again
the policies went back to the kind of
zero tolerance approach and today my
sense is although i'm not an expert on
the topic but my sense is the laws are
pretty harsh
and the availability of treatment is
less much less than it was
in the nixon era although as i go into
in the book what nixon called treatment
many of the soldiers actually saw his
incarceration because they had to stay
in vietnam
if they tested positive for heroin and
that was the worst thing because all the
soldiers were counting their derose
state of expected return from overseas
was their magic number you know get out
of jail because you know most the
soldiers really hated saw the place hell
and you know wanted to get out alive so
for them to have to stay five extra days
to go through this army treatment
program and then the program like i mean
there are many good treatment facilities
out there but a lot of treatment program
some treatment programs are run in a
very authoritarian or draconian way so
that you know patients don't benefit or
come to see it as like an incarceration
and that was certainly true of the army
programs in the 70s so
i wouldn't qualify them as all success
but in some ways it was moving towards a
more progressive policy than what took
root under reagan and we see now a
pretty harsh attitude
in part because of this historical
legacy but
but that gives a basic trajectory
but yeah i was always frowned upon but
alcohol the irony is that alcohol has
always been a much bigger problem so
i just want to thank you and commend you
for the research i think it's very
important and i wanted to ask your
opinion and maybe you know this from
working with
you know other researchers but
what what's the public awareness on this
issue currently
where does the average person stand
with regards to the knowledge and the
research that you presented here and
i've read some of your recent articles
and you kind of touched on it you know
linking the war in afghanistan and
karzai's brother who is
could be one of the largest drug
traffickers in the world today still
getting the go-ahead
uh you know from from some type of
u.s agency
and where do we stand with regards to
public awareness of this it's
i could i could only speak for myself
and i was quite shocked by a lot of you
know i read a few extras from the book
and in your speech and then even
learning about afghanistan where do we
stand in terms of today the average
person with their awareness of these
issues well that's a very good question
yeah so the question is you know public
awareness
particularly some of the uh more you
know controversial and hypocritical
elements of the drug war well with
regards to afghanistan it was exposed in
the new york times
all this is now almost nine years into
the war but there was a in i think
november a big article came out written
by dexter filkins
about the corruption of karzai and he
quoted a cia official saying
you know if you're looking for mother
teresa in afghanistan you're not going
to find her and almost every uh leading
officials and has some involvement with
the drug trade and that's new york times
so
which is you know no radical paper
and obviously has a wide audience it was
a very well written uh researched uh
piece um
so it's becoming increasingly well known
i mean this is nine years into that
conflict
and there is quite a large body of
literature you know
alfred mccoy wrote the pioneering book
in the early 70s as well as peter dale
scott's been researching the you know
cia involvement and yeah i was surprised
myself before i researched this i saw it
as maybe something of a conspiracy
theory but it's only when i went into
the national archives and there's some
of the evidence in the book
and found memos from government
officials for instance like the
ambassador to laos would be
communicating with the state department
and saying
yeah you know these guys are corrupt up
to their ears but they're fighting a war
for us so
you know there's nothing we can do about
it you know that's candidly expressed in
many of the memos
so and now those would only be
accessible to researchers so
yeah i mean my sense is the public is
not aware of a lot of things
in part because it's often not well
covered in the media that new york times
piece may have been an exception
and the mainstream press actually giving
attention to that issue so
my sense is you know there are very
informed and well-educated people who
know about this but the majority
probably don't and that's why you know
people maybe continue to support
policies when they don't have all the
information because yeah i mean the
paradox is just so blatant if the us is
indirectly or maybe directly supporting
groups that are you know major
traffickers
because we know afghanistan is 93
percent of heroin comes out of
afghanistan it's a major and since i
mean the numbers
since the u.s invaded when you know the
taliban had actually cracked down on it
which bears some resemblances to the
cold war years because the chinese
communists for all their flaws you know
put in a drug policy uh that was very
strict in part because of the legacy of
british colonialism and the opium wars
and british drug trafficking in china
it was a symbol of anti-imperialism that
they were going to crack down harshly on
and so uh it's often the u.s opponents
that actually do a job now that the
record of the chinese and civil
liberties was not very good but
but the same was true of the taliban as
when the u.s invaded that the numbers
went way up in part because the climate
of war is conducive to all kinds of
illegal enterprise to fund counter
insurgency operations so
but yeah in terms of public awareness
my sense is a lot of people aren't
well enough informed
so
in your book you reference how the use
of marijuana by vietnam soldiers was a
self
medicating action similar to alcohol
but without the hangover the following
day which could endanger fellow
soldiers in combat
this was acknowledged by military
psychiatrists and seems to continue to
support the belief that marijuana is
indeed safer than alcohol
could you elaborate further on this and
tell us what your thoughts are on the
newly released studies that encourage
marijuana use
as a treatment of post-traumatic stress
disorder
okay
the question is
well two-fold yeah the reference in the
book to soldiers who stated that uh they
preferred marijuana to alcohol because
it didn't have a hangover effect and uh
the effects of medical marijuana
well i'm not an expert on
the pharmacological effects of marijuana
so i can't really answer the second
question in terms of
marijuana and ptsd
but i can't answer the question my sense
from studying the you know experience of
vietnam veterans
well is first and i think most these
studies have shown alcohol to be one of
the most dangerous particularly you know
abuse i mean every drug there's a
difference between use and abuse that
often gets lost in some of the hyperbole
so alcohol can be used safely but when
alcohol is abused it can cause many many
problems
from drunk driving to liver disease on
down
and many studies have attributed you
know
major social problems uh to alcohol
abuse including things like domestic
preferred you know in discussing the
discrepancy many prefer like going on a
mission
if they were asked you know would you
prefer to go on a mission with an
alcoholic or somebody who smoked
marijuana they often
you know preferred
marijuana because as you pointed out it
doesn't have the hangover effect
and is seen as
i mean there are mixed studies but it's
generally seen as relatively harmless if
not abused
so
and there was you know some did use it
for self-medicating effects and actually
what i found interesting in my research
as i i think i came out with something
of an open mind was that
a lot of the reports actually refer to
good performance and there's evidence in
the book that those soldiers who were
using drugs weren't necessarily problems
in their units and there's a number of
reports and i cited like army reports uh
that you know this guy was cited for uh
heroin possession but he was among the
best guys in the unit
uh and veterans i interviewed said you
know we would either use it on our spare
i mean a factor was we would use it on
our spare time or they knew how to
moderate their level of intake you know
because they didn't want to risk their
own lives especially that they were in
combat so they might use a little bit
but they wouldn't use at the level that
would
you know in any way impair them so and
the evidence i present is that alcohol
was a very big problem and acknowledged
to be
as high as westmoreland uh the top of
the army you know they were doing
studies on this because of the
stories that were coming out and that
was the military's conclusion that drug
alcohol was an epidemic in the military
something like 93 percent used it and
many in the officers you know used it to
extreme and there was a culture of in
the military of uh you know new recruits
would be uh much like maybe in some
fraternities where they just drink
totally to excess to the point where
people and i have evidence in the book
where guys you know doctor one guy
interviewed said you know the doctor was
drunk as a skunk
and he couldn't treat a guy who was
wounded now there may have been stories
like that about drugs as well but my
sense of from the research i've seen is
that alcohol is much more of a problem
certainly than marijuana which is uh
again the medical literature is quite
clear that you know
marijuana may have certain
[Music]
damaging consequences but
is considered by most specialists to be
relatively harmless so
um
[Music]
so that's my sense from but again i'm
not a
scientist or pharmacologist but i think
it is quite illuminating what just the
testimony of the veterans uh
in the war and the psych the medical
psychologists uh whom i rely on uh
for a lot of the evidence
yeah i'll follow up and then uh
one more question um also as you
illustrated in your speech walter
cronkite introduced john steinbeck and
fourth in the 1967 nbc interview saying
the communists are battling american
troops not only with fire power but with
drugs however years later cronkite
conducted a journalistic piece
entitled the war on drugs where he took
a far different approach
and at times spoke contrary to his
original statements
what do you think caused him and for the
most part the rest of the media to
change their reporting position in that
40-year time period
well i guess i mean there was some
commitment to the truth
and the evidence did come out
i mean and it shows that in 67 he was
probably fed that report and actually
there was a deliberate campaign on
behalf of people like edward lansdale
within the cia
you know to drum up support for the war
and to demonize the communists
and part of the cold war environment in
the country so maybe originally he
didn't think much about it that you know
he probably imbued many of the cold war
ideology of the time period or he was
just fed the information and took it
from the military and took it to be fact
but then when all the evidence came out
years later at least
give him credit for having some
commitment to
the truth because a lot i mean mccoy's
book uh on the politics of heroin and
the cia complicity is a very well
researched uh book uh which as actually
the cia in 2016
they wrote an internal history of the
secret war in laos
um and there it was only declassified in
2006 and their synopsis was that indeed
you know the cia was involved
caught up in the drug traffic and they
even referred to mccoy's research as
being you know excellent and on the mark
internally even though at the time they
actually harassed him and
tried to prevent publishing the book so
i mean that well-researched book came
out in the early 70s and a lot of
additional information came out
that it was hard to make those claims
year later years later with any kind of
credibility but at the time yeah it
shows how the media sometimes operates
is that they just rely on either a
briefing by the military or maybe just
their own assumptions
from that time period that eventually
did get discredited but
but that's interesting i didn't know
that about concrete concrete
specifically but yeah i did say i mean
the washington post admitted i cited a
quote in 1980 that they acknowledged
that they had exaggerated
this fear of return of veterans coming
back so yeah some of them did print
retract retractions which is nice to see
but the damage was done already so
and it provides good evidence um
for the argument that it was exaggerated
if even their the sources for doing it
were admitting that they exaggerated so
i just
the original question from the gentleman
um
you know i and it's kind of comment but
also question to you
uh i would i would say that probably the
type of marijuana that these soldiers
were smoking in vietnam is drastically
different from
what is commonly available today
um
is that much more potent yeah
it is now yeah it means like the purity
whereas alcohol is probably
alcohol it was alcohol it's the same
thing today but it's probably a very
different
variety or type to what is commonly
available today is that covered at all
in the book or yeah because they were
and that was one of the fears of the
military and others that the pure the
level of purity of both the heroin and
marijuana was so high that especially
when they would come back to the u.s
they would be craving you know stronger
and stronger drugs
so that was a big fear
of the policy makers
and yeah i mean i interviewed veterans
who had experiences where they freaked
out and
but one point i make was that it was in
part you know the
the environment of the war that they
freaked out when taking the substance
because they were already you know fear
i mean the experience of soldiers was
often a terrible one and they were you
know fearing their lives uh and they
were already in a state of paranoia so
maybe in some cases you know the
marijuana or taking some substance put
them over the edge but it's not to say
that you know marijuana causes people to
go crazy even even in a relatively high
potency so but it was used that was one
of the fears that because the purity was
high in vietnam that it would cause
problems back in the us
quality would have been lower in
vietnam at that time no it was grown by
farmers
yeah and some of them resisted when the
u.s tried to spray their fields but the
level of purity was very high both for
the heroin
and for the marijuana
because it was locally grown
so
is there any truth to the myth that a
lot of our soldiers brought back
um varieties of marijuana
to the u.s and that became part of the
new drug movement of that time uh you
know we hear about the bikers that were
vets that started
and really that's when it all exploded
is there any truth to that or is that my
sense yeah the film american gangster
made the claim that
i forget the the individual anybody
remember the name
of the gang what's his name frank uh
frank lucas uh they claim he was
smuggling uh in the coffins of
dead american soldiers uh there is one
case where that was revealed
that three american soldiers one of them
african-americans out of thailand
were trying to do that uh there were
also cases where soldiers were male
drugs back until around 68 69 they
started to crack down on that but my
sense and i make the point of the book
is that that got exaggerated because the
major source of heroin into the united
states was mexico which was estimated to
be about 80 percent so uh yes it may
have affected supply rates to a certain
degree but i don't think uh the explo i
mean there was an influx of drugs drug
use in the 70s although it did get
exaggerated
and yeah there was a wide availability
in many cities including new york
and it may have been in small measure
because the golden triangle traffic was
making its way into the u.s but it was
for the most part heroin from mexico
from what i've seen and that's got
greatly exaggerated even the lucas story
um
dea agents who are often actually quite
candid
and many have come out and written you
know books
about the corruptions of the drug war
and about the complicity of the cia have
said that
there's no evidence of these smuggling
rackets by veterans from thailand that
was trumped up in films like american
gangsters my sense
that it's another thing that got
exaggerated the length of vietnam war
because i think the problem of drug use
that developed in the 70s
and late 60s particularly hard drug use
was the product of the breakdown of the
inner cities and the structural problems
that the country was experiencing and
the supply rate
i mean the supply again was largely from
mexico so what was going on in vietnam
if at best had only a minor effect in
affecting supply rates
so and there was never the level of
purity in new york that there was in
saigon so
at the back yeah
i'd like to speak from personal
experience to the question of the
potency of vietnamese and thai wheat
the high
potency marijuana that is available
today
that comes to us through the breeders in
amsterdam
that marijuana started with seeds from
among other places southeast asia
very high potency cannabis
types because of the equatorial growing
conditions where cannabis sativa
predominates
also from afghanistan and the mountains
of tibet
getting your afghani varieties but the
the weed that was available in vietnam
and thailand laos
far exceeded
equality and potency what was available
to americans in america at the time
i know that from personal experience
uh the other question i've got is
both in frank lucas's movie
american gangster
and in the movie about
charlie wilson
concerning the afghani adventure
and in the documentary about charlie
wilson all three places
none of the drugs are mentioned at all
and yet we know that the uh the majority
of the money that funded afghanistan was
from heroin
not from us congress provided by charlie
wilson
could you speak to that
oh thanks and i think that gets the
point uh you know earlier about public
uh knowledge is not very good because
yeah these kind of popular the fiction
depictions just totally whitewash it and
yeah i should have mentioned that as a
major precursor and actually there was
an editorial in 79 david musto who
worked for the state department as a
expert at yale university and drug
policy
he wrote an editorial like uh warning
the carter administration you know don't
do what we did in laos and support uh
drug traffickers uh of course they went
ahead you know go budden hikmatiar was
the uh and that was one of the you know
terrible things that the u.s did in
afghanistan was to arm the extremist
elements
in afghanistan against the soviet union
and their you know the cia favorite was
gul budden hikmatiar the head of the his
b islami organization who is known for
throwing acid in the face of women and
he was also a major heroin trafficker
now he's fighting against the u.s
although yeah the u.s may be trying to
recruit him i don't know
it's oh really
that wouldn't surprise me because
they're working with all kinds of
warlords who are involved in those
earlier campaigns but yeah there's a lot
of evidence about his
corruption as well as the pakistani isi
stemming from those wars in the 80s
because most the afghan cia operation
was funded through the isi
particularly when the reagan
administration cozied up to zia al hook
the pakistani military dictator in the
early 80s
and that you know corruption within the
isi is
through the roof as it is today and the
isi may also be funding the taliban
so uh it's a mess
u.s policy there but you know these are
factors contributing to a skyrocketing i
think of
and that's become the center of the
world drug trade and many have pointed
out mccoy i mean the real experts in
this field are alfred mccoy and peter
dale scott and they've pointed out that
where the u.s intervenes it often
becomes the center of the world drug
trade in part because of who their
allies are and in part because of the
client conditions of war are conducive
to black market operations
and you know people need arms and you'll
need money quickly and an easy way to
make money in those regions where there
are limited resources and when their
opium is a important cash crop
that's a you know big way of funding
these military operations so yeah no
thank you for pointing it out and that's
uh
you know that that operation in the 80s
uh
was another example also in central
america it came out that you know with
the iran contra scandal uh that oliver
north was involved with the contras and
uh you know drug practices gary webb
exposed that um and there's quite a bit
of evidence that's come out uh
about how you know those wars uh dirty
wars in the 80s were funded so and we
may be seeing you although it doesn't
get reported but in colombia as well how
was
you know the corruption of the uribe
government and
how are some of those i mean we know the
u.s is pouring a lot of money into
colombia today but there may you know be
also illicit means of funding some of
those paramilitary groups that are
loosely allied with the colombian
military involved in the operations
against the farc so it's not necessarily
by coincidence that these regions of
conflict that the us is involved in
become centers of the drug trade so yeah
if we're really concerned about
eliminating drugs we should focus on
that problem and stop funding these
wars that are very destructive and also
contributing to the boom of the drug
trade
since you asked already i think but
well yeah um
a big outcry against the war was based
in the universities from the college
students
was any part of that
towards the uh invalidity of the drug
war
um that's a good question um
i i'm not sure i think most it was
against the war actually that was used
and i go into this a bit in the book
is they actually use that as evidence of
how corrupt and tainted this war was
that you know even the soldiers were
becoming addicted and the cia was
supplying them so i think that was used
and ironically that's one thing i i
argue is that it's one way in which the
anti-war movement ironically uh
kind of played a little bit into nixon's
agenda because they used some of the
same rhetoric
uh as um you know politicians even of
the right uh you know they exaggerated
at times the scope of drug abuse because
it was part of their anti-war criticism
and even you know senator george
mcgovern who had first
sponsored a bill in 65 calling for
withdrawal
if i can find the page i can briefly
read
you know he he employed quite a bit of
exaggeration himself
it's in this chapter i'll
quickly point to uh
you know mcgovern um he said um
you know
quoting mcgovern uh he said america's
foreign entanglement was coming to haunt
the nation through the addiction of
american soldiers and he claimed that a
hundred thousand of them were using
drugs which was an exaggeration
uh and he said i challenge you to
explain how the north vietnamese are a
greater threat to
our national security than the crime
violence and internal decay caused by
narcotics
and then he said the next president can
act to end the war and crack down on the
supply of heroin from southeast asia
this is the fight america should be
pursuing which is the war on drugs so
the democrat it was a bipartisan policy
and many in the anti-war movement
actually
tacitly at least supported it
but yeah in later years
i think many students and others would
come to criticize it but in that period
i mean they're focused
rightfully i think because of how
horrible the war was was on the vietnam
war and that's one of the ironies is how
the vietnam war led to the escalation of
another disastrous war so
you speak a lot about the production end
of drugs heroin cocaine and
a lot of combat zones in which the
united states has been involved
what could you say about the receiving
end things like for example the airport
in mina that was rumored to have
received narcotics under governor
clinton
and
the airport in mina i believe in 1991 or
so that was rumored to have received
narcotics um
about
100 miles south of here oh okay it's in
it's in western arkansas okay um i guess
it was chosen as a location because it's
remoteness and
that it's not well known to the american
populace
what can you say about the receiving end
for covert drugs through the cia
that i i don't have any evidence myself
so i can't say positively or negatively
yeah my sense is i mean there are um
you know some cases it may be
exaggerated the role of the cia
i don't know i i mean you know in terms
of their direct role or
i mean my sense is it's often more kind
of quid pro quo alliance they make with
uh regimes or
[Music]
groups that they're allied with that
they're not necessarily directly
transporting it in the country at least
i haven't seen that much evidence it's
certainly within the realm of
possibility but i have not seen any
direct evidence so i can't
answer to that
question
but yeah i mean a lot of the intrigues
do breed suspicion
so i i don't blame people for being
suspicious and it may very well be
that there is uh you know corruption a
lot of corruption going on i just i
personally haven't seen the evidence to
be able to comment one way or the other
so
another thing also is
a lot of people say that the
drug industry as far as pharmaceuticals
go
is fighting marijuana basically because
they don't want they don't want
consumers to be able to grow their own
medicine at home
could nixon have had any sort of
maybe
special interest groups that
push towards the
drug addicted army
um again it's not something i explored
but it's i think certainly the case uh
that special interests uh
you know and i mean the drug comp you
know it's a question of why are certain
drugs legal and certain drugs illegal
and it's often politics and not uh or
you know connections uh or the interests
of the pharmaceutical companies so
but i i haven't done much direct
research on that and that would be an
interesting you know project for a
course or thesis uh to explore the
influence of the pharmaceutical company
across time perhaps it would be a great
thesis if anybody
wants to write a phd or so it's very
interesting question yeah i just don't
have all the evidence but i i would
certainly suspect it's a factor
and it's sometimes hard to document
because it's not always you know there
it may not make its way into an archive
or any official government hearings but
as we know lobbyists play a very
powerful role in washington so
it's yeah
we seem to you know talk a little bit
and in the recent articles in the book
definitely there's a focus here on
uh government policy government action
and
and drug policy and where we where we
stand as a as a nation and i was
wondering if in your future work if you
plan to continue
to delve into this topic you also
mentioned
uh and i think there's another you know
call it a myth but it might be in fact a
fact the same way this one you know
people call it say myths and then this
is now fact that you know that this was
not uh
the reason that we lost the war let's
say was the drug use so another
question i have for you is
um you know we've heard about for years
cia
spreading crack cocaine in
inner cities
really catapulting that problem and
making that
spreading drug use to
to [ __ ] uh or worsen our society
is there any given inclination in your
future research to continue down this
path
uh well thanks for the question yeah for
crack cocaine i i haven't seen the
evidence i mean the web expose showed uh
and other works uh that clearly the you
know the contras were involved uh and
there was certainly a cover-up uh
involving the cia and there may have
been you know people like oliver north
directly involved in using drugs to fund
the country operations whether there was
an overt cia plot
to flood the country with a crack it may
be a bit far-fetched i mean i don't
think the cia deliberately wants to
spread the drug traffic i just think
it's a byproduct of their interventions
and they get caught up in it because of
the kinds of activities they're carrying
out so that would be my perspective but
yeah they're i mean there may be more
evidence that comes to light on that
personally yeah i mean i plan on
continuing this area i'm currently
writing a book on american police
training
training police
for mainly
showing i'm trying to show a continuity
in policy from the u.s occupation the
philippines at the turn of the 20th
century through the cold war years uh
and how these programs often led to a
lot of human rights violations and kind
of skyr spy rock skyrocket out of
control
so that's my current focus but it does
tie to what i'm discussing here because
one reason the us was training police
was for drug war purposes but in a lot
of cases that was really just the public
reason that really they wanted to train
police to go after guerrilla groups
like in colombia for instance it was
convenient to say the guerrillas were
involved in the drug trade which is how
they can get congressional funding for
programs like police training but in
fact uh it was for the most part the
cartels there may have been some
involvement to the gorillas although uh
it was you know likely mainly relegated
to taxing
you know coca growing in their areas
that they controlled and you know the
cartels were on the right wing in the
spectrum and often you know had
connections with the government so but
that they used that narco guerrilla to
justify police training programs which
are really designed for counter
insurgency and to fight these you know
the u.s historically has opposed
left-wing social movements for a variety
of reasons ideological economic uh the
you know fear of
threats to u.s investment opportunities
so
so that's my current focus more on the
police training in the military
dimension but
yeah i'll certainly continue to keep an
interest in these areas so
and there are other scholars working in
the field so
great well i think is that
great well thank you very much for your
excellent question
[Applause]
thanks very good
very good question oh thanks thank you
good questions adam i appreciate that
jeremy kuzmarov is an assistant history
professor at the university of tulsa to
find out more visit umass.edu
um press
this weekend on c-span 2's book tv from
new york this year's national book